la parole est à Monsieur Mathieu
Lefebvre rapporteur de la commission des
lois constitutionnelles de la
législation et de l'administration
générale de la République
merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires européennes madame la
vice-présidente dans la commission des
lois madame la ministre mes chers
collègues nous sommes ici réunis le 9
mai Journée de l'Europe qui rend hommage
à la déclaration de Robert Schuman en
1950 en cette journée symbolique j'ai
l'honneur de rapporter une proposition
de loi qu'il est tout autant et je
l'assume j'en profite pour remercier la
présidente de notre groupe Aurore berger
pour son engagement européen que je sais
cheviller au corps car symbolique mes
chers collègues ne veut pas dire
anecdotique bien au contraire et ceux
qui balayent d'un trait de plumes les
symboles en dehors du champ du débat
public contreviennent en réalité à notre
Constitution et à ces articles 2 et 88
cette république que d'aucun de part et
d'autre de notre hémicycle juge mauvaise
sans avoir les moyens démocratiques de
la changer
ce qui balaie d'un trade plume
l'histoire d'un drapeau n'est 50 ans
avant le traité constitutionnel de 2005
en méconnesse également le sens et la
portée et ils iront expliquer à
l'Ukraine membre du Conseil de l'Europe
que la France refuse de se prévaloir
d'un drapeau qui a quel arbore à la
recherche d'une paix abimée par la haine
ce sont d'ailleurs en général les mêmes
qui à l'instar de Madame Le Pen propose
soit de retirer le drapeau européen de
tous les bâtiments publics ou ceux comme
Monsieur Mélenchon qui sont indignés
devant la présence de ce qu'il nomme une
forfaiture démocratique au sein de notre
assemblée
si les symboles n'avaient pas
d'importance jamais le rassemblement
national dans les proposer de rapatrier
les cendres de Napoléon III si les
symboles n'avaient pas d'importance
jamais les insoumis n'aurait proposé de
pas poser cette hémicycle aux couleurs
des Nations Unies à dire vrai ceux qui
s'opposent aux pavoisement de nos
mairies symboles de la proximité et de
la vitalité du pacte républicain aux
couleurs tricolores et européennes ne
s'opposent pas au drapeau mais à l'idée
européenne elle-même j'en profite de ce
point de vue pour remercier nos
collègues écologistes et singulièrement
la présidente chacun pour leur cohérence
sur ce sujet
ne nous cachons pas mes chers collègues
derrière des faux sanglants juridiques
pour rejeter une proposition que
j'assume politique en cette journée si
symbolique en réalité ceux qui parmi
nous ont du mal à masquer leur malaise
face au drapeau étoilé en tout autant de
mal à masquer leur rêve de frexit
déguisés rouge pour les uns et bruns
pour les autres ne nous cachons pas
derrière des faux sanglants juridiques
du rassemblement national à la France
insoumise ils nous disent de conserve
vouloir faire prévaloir leur propre
programme sur les traités et les règles
communes comme si l'on pouvait s'en
extraire sans conséquence pour notre
pays et pour les Français c'est votre
droit mes chers collègues mais vous irez
vous assumerez ces conséquences devant
les Français et vous en assumerez les
risques que vous ferez courir à notre
pays ces conséquences nous ne les
connaissions que trop bien isolement des
agrégations et fragilisation d'un
édifice vecteur de paix de démocratie et
de prospérité
au gros Renaissance tout au contraire
nous sommes fiers de réaffirmer notre
attachement au projet européen notre
attachement à l'idéal des pères
fondateurs et nous le sommes mes chers
collègues d'autant plus en cette heure
où les armes sévissent à nouveau sur
notre continent
et ceux qui s'y opposeront ne
s'opposeront pas aux morceaux de tissu
sur lequel ils sont amenés à se
prononcer mes chers collègues mais aux
valeurs elles-mêmes que ceux-ci
charrient et que nos prédécesseurs ont
arraché et défendu de haute luttes ces
valeurs ce sont les droits de l'homme le
plus réalisme la démocratie l'unité
nationale et la cohésion entre les États
européens
ils trouveront les mots mes chers
collègues pour expliquer leur refus il
trouvant les mots pour expliquer leur
refus au héros de la place maïdan en
Ukraine qui l'arborait fièrement face à
la répression ils iront l'expliquer
également au Géorgiens qui brandissaient
ce drapeau en étant d'art face à
l'oppresseur russe et le trouveront les
mots pour l'expliquer au président de
ski qui a présidé en montrant une photo
du drapeau européen et du drapeau
ukrainien par le passé mes chers
collègues notre Assemblée a été conduite
à légiférer sur ce sujet sans que cela
ne vaille discorde bien au contraire en
2013 à l'occasion d'une loi apportée par
le gouvernement héros un amendement
parlementaire à l'initiative de l'UMP a
proposé le pavoisement de nos écoles aux
couleurs tricolores et européennes cet
amendement a été mes chers collègues
adopté à l'unanimité que s'est-il passé
pour que 10 ans plus tard nous soyons
incapables de nous réunir autour de ces
valeurs de cohésion pourquoi refuser
refuser que nos mairies symboles de
proximité républicaine auquel les
Français sont à raison attachés fassent
l'objet le traitements différents de nos
écoles entre temps ceux qui voulaient
sortir de l'euro ce sont convertis à la
monnaie unique entre temps ceux qui
voulaient sortir de l'espace Schengen
qui sont convertis entre temps ceux qui
voulaient quitter l'Union ont préféré la
quitter de l'intérieur dans une
préférence nationale qui s'y est tant à
l'extrême gauche qu'à l'extrême droite
et mes chers collègues vouloir plus
d'Europe ça n'est pas vouloir moins de
France et penser la citoyenneté
européenne comme c'est le cas depuis
Maastricht ne signifie pas se substituer
à l'identité française en vérité la
haine de l'Europe relève d'une peur
panique du changement et de l'altérité
dont se nourrissent les populismes alors
je vous le dis tout net
nous ne sommes pas et il n'y a pas dans
cette hémicycle des euro Béa nul
n'ignore les failles les frustrations
les échecs parfois de la vie à 27 et
chacun nous mesurerons les attendre que
forme concitoyens en direction d'une
Europe plus concrète et ancrée dans leur
quotidien mais je le dis avec tout
autant d'évidences ceux qui croient que
nous pourrons exister seul dans le
concert des nations coincé entre les
États-Unis et la Chine ceux qui croient
qu'il est possible d'aider nos frères
Ukrainiens sans aucune coordination ce
qui pense que la bataille climatique
peut se limiter au strict cadre de nos
frontières hexagonales cela mentent aux
Français
ceux-là sont en général très pro à
passer sous silence toutes les réussites
de l'Union taxe carbone assez frontières
imposition minimale des grands groupes
relance budgétaires pendant la crise
sanitaire régulation des géants du
numérique je pourrais continuer ainsi
égrainer tous les succès obtenus pendant
la présidence française de l'Union
européenne mes chers collègues nos
débats nous donneront l'occasion de
revenir dans le détail des points
d'achauffement de ce texte comme des
reproches techniques fondées ou non qui
lui ont été faits je pense à la question
de la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales ou bien au
coût que ferait porter cette charge aux
municipalités comme là à juste titre
soulevé le groupe horizon mais je le
redis le vote le vote qui sera le vôtre
tout à l'heure sera un vote en faveur ou
en défaveur de la construction
européenne ni plus ni moins il
départagera ceux qui considèrent que
sans la France l'Europe ne serait pas
l'Europe et que sans l'Europe la France
ne serait pas la France de ceux qui ont
le drapeau et la construction européenne
honteux
certains je ne mets cependant pas sur le
même plan ceux qui ont exprimé des
réserves sur ce texte en raison du coup
précisément que peut représenter le
paroisement pour les plus petites
communes certains se sont abstenus pour
cette raison en commission ce qui a
entraîné l'adoption des amendements de
suppression je pense en particulier à
nos côtés à nos collègues du modèle dont
chacun connaît l'attachement à l'Europe
j'ai entendu ces réserves nous avons
parfaitement conscience que le
paroisement peut représenter un coup
important pour les petites communes
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
proposé un avis favorable à l'amendement
de notre collègue Solignac pour en
dispenser les communes de moins de 3500
habitants que notre collègue Roberto
proposera des temps aux communes de
moins de 1500 habitants
je pense que nous pourrons de cette
façon mes chers collègues trouvez un
terrain de compromis qui permettra de
réunir une majorité de voix dans cette
hémicycle et vous me permettrez puisque
j'ai évoqué un amendement socialiste mes
chers collègues
de conclure de conclure en citant le
président Mitterrand et plus
particulièrement ses vœux du 31 décembre
1994 les derniers qu'il est présenté à
la nation si cette intervention est
restée dans les mémoires pour sa
conclusion uniformé également souffrait
qu'on puisse entendre le président
Mitterrand dans cette émission
ne séparez jamais la grandeur de la
France et la construction de l'Europe
c'est notre nouvelle dimension et notre
ambition pour le siècle prochain voilà
ce que disait le président Mitterrand et
voilà où on est aujourd'hui la France
insoumise et c'est bien là mes chers
collègues le sens de notre débat un
symbole oui et trois fois oui mais un
symbole plus que jamais
utile dans la France et dans l'Europe
d'aujourd'hui c'est la raison pour
laquelle mes chers collègues j'invite
tous ceux qui dans cette hémicycle
savent que c'est lorsqu'elle assume son
destin européen que la France se grandit
a adopter cette proposition de loi je
vous remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Laurence bonne
secrétaire d'État chargée de l'Europe
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires européennes
madame la Vice-Présidente de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteur et messieurs et mesdames les
députés
en novembre 2013
à Bucarest en février 2017
en Pologne en octobre 2021
mars dernier quand il manifeste pour la
paix pour la liberté pour les droits des
femmes contre la corruption c'est le
drapeau européen que brandissent les
peuples d'Europe
ces peuples qui se soulèvent en
brandissant le drapeau européen
incarne ses paroles prononcées par
Robert Schuman il y a 73 ans aujourd'hui
dans le salon de l'horloge du Quai
d'Orsay pour que la paix puisse vraiment
courir sa chance il faut d'abord qu'il y
ait une Europe
et toujours dans ces manifestations le
drapeau européen est accompagné il est
accompagné des drapeaux des pays de ces
peuples qui se lèvent car le drapeau
européen ne vient pas seul il vient
toujours avec les étangs nationaux il
leur est consubstantiellement lié
et de même
l'identité européenne complète
harmonieusement les identités nationales
elle n'enlève rien elle ne retranche
rien elle augmente nos identités parce
que l'Europe renforce notre souveraineté
porter les couleurs de l'Europe c'est
affirmé des valeurs communes je sais ça
vous échappe la démocratie la liberté
l'État de droit
porter les couleurs de l'Europe c'est
affirmé que nous sommes unis dans la
diversité
[Applaudissements]
porter les couleurs de l'Europe c'est
les afficher au fronton de nos mairies
aux côtés de nos couleurs nationales
c'est bien l'expression que cette union
dans l'anniversaire nous rend plus fort
c'est bien le sens de la proposition de
loi qui nous est proposée aujourd'hui
déposé par Mathieu Lefebvre qui vise à
rendre obligatoire le pavoisement du
drapeau français et du drapeau européen
sur le fronton de nos mairies
alors j'entends j'entends ceux qui
disent que cette assemblée devrait
plutôt se préoccuper de l'inflation du
pouvoir d'achat et des soucis quotidiens
des Français car oui la situation reste
difficile pour trop de Français mais il
n'y a pas d'opposition ni de
substitution entre toutes les lois qui
ont été adoptées depuis des mois et pas
par vous pour protéger les Français
contre la vie chère contre l'énergie
cher qui est le résultat de l'agression
russe en Ukraine et l'importance de ce
que représente ce drapeau
nous avons mis en place les boucliers
nécessaires pour protéger les Français
et nous continuons de le faire
la solidarité européenne a assuré
l'approvisionnement de l'énergie cet
hiver
réaffirmer nos valeurs européennes quand
populiste d'extrême droite ou d'extrême
gauche
instrumentalisent tous les jours les
difficultés des français cherchent à
diviser les Français c'est réaffirmer
l'unité de notre peuple français tous
citoyens européens
cette proposition devrait nous
rassembler elle devrait nous réunir
parce qu'elle s'inscrit dans un
mouvement qui a débuté en 2008 et qui a
été porté par toutes les majorités
le 10 janvier 2016
dans ce même hémicycle
Catherine Colonna avait formé un vœu
celui que vienne le jour où dans cette
émission le drapeau européen serait
présent à côté du drapeau français
un an plus tard son vœu fut exaucé le
président hakoyé proposé à votre bureau
d'installer le drapeau européen dans
l'hémicycle ce fut accepté il ne l'a
plus quitté il est là au cœur de notre
démocratie
[Applaudissements]
en 2013 Mathieu Lefevre le rappelait
votre assemblée a décidé de rendre
obligatoire le drapeau européen aux
côtés du drapeau français au fronton de
nos écoles cet amendement de la majorité
socialiste de l'époque avait été
largement soutenu
en 2019
cette érikioti qui avait proposé que le
drapeau français et le drapeau européen
soit obligatoirement affichée dans
chacune des salles de classe des
établissements du premier et du second
degré public ou privé sous contrat tous
les matins tous les matins en allant à
l'école nos enfants leurs parents voici
deux drapeaux à coller
enfin
cette assemblée a adopté le 27 novembre
2017 une résolution encourageant le
gouvernement a promouvoir les symboles
européens de matière complémentaire au
symbole nationaux et la proposition de
loi qui vous est proposée aujourd'hui
elle concrétise cette résolution
alors évidemment
le rassemblement national a toujours
combattu ce mouvement mais oui et j'ai
entendu dernièrement un député j'espère
qu'il est présent sur ces bancs
Jean-Philippe Tanguy affirmait que le
drapeau européen ne renvoyait à aucune
histoire
aucun symbole mais vraiment mais je ne
vous ferai pas l'injure de vous rappeler
que c'est un 9 mai que l'histoire de
l'Union européenne a commencé avec la
Communauté européenne du charbon et de
l'acier dans un discours à Paris
j'espère que vous en rappelez
ce jour-là le 9 mai 1950 Robert Schuman
appelé dans son discours l'Europe n'a
pas été faite nous avons eu la guerre
l'Union européenne c'est Monsieur
l'histoire de la France depuis la fin de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale et la
construction
et la construction européenne depuis
c'est le renforcement cohérent et
constant de la souveraineté de la France
et du continent alors oui monsieur
Tanguy alors oui mesdames et messieurs
l'Europe a une histoire
et de nouveau je ne ferai l'injure à
personne de rappeler ce que la
construction européenne doit à la France
que dirais-je Jean Monnet
que dirait Robert Schuman que dirait
Simone Veil que dirait Jacques Delors
étant d'autres mais comment est-il
possible de nier cela
[Applaudissements]
alors même
alors même que l'Europe se tient droit
et ses États membres unis face à
l'agression russe en Ukraine
la guerre à nos portes
je vous le rappelle parce que parfois
vous oubliez l'histoire les tensions
géopolitiques la montée des autocraties
les fausses informations sont autant de
défis pour la construction européenne
qui nous demande de rester unis et c'est
bien pourquoi le président porte la
notion de souveraineté européenne qui
change l'Europe pour que l'Europe soit
plus forte et plus protectrice
remettre en cause l'Europe mesdames et
messieurs les députés je vous le dis
c'est faire le jeu de Poutine et de tous
les autocrates
[Applaudissements]
mais le rassemblement national n'est pas
seul dans ce rejet de l'Europe
je le rappelais le drapeau européen
était moins des débats de cette émission
depuis 2008 et c'est d'ailleurs Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui avait fait mine de s'en
offusquer lorsqu'il avait rejoint
l'Assemblée nationale en 2017
c'est Manon hubry député député
européenne
qui dit le drapeau européen ça renvoie
aussi à une forte démocratique quand on
est français mais comme disait Mélanie
Vogel sérieusement le traité de Lisbonne
a été signé par la France et ratifiée
par 560 députés français et oui
alors
alors à ceux qui disent que cette
proposition de loi ne servirait à rien
à tout cela je réponds au contraire elle
vise à sécuriser la présence de ce
drapeau face au velléité de celles et
ceux qui le rejettent et qui veulent
affaiblir la France et je le redis il ne
s'agit pas de le remplacer le drapeau
français mais de le renforcer car comme
le disait Lionel Jospin nous voulons
faire l'Europe sans défaire la France
alors le drapeau européen symbolise cet
appartenance des citoyens à l'oignon
européenne
appartenance que nous avions placé au
cœur de notre action lors de notre
président du Conseil l'an dernier
ce drapeau européen auquel vous l'auriez
oublié nous rappelle que chaque citoyen
d'un État membre est aussi citoyen
européen et d'ailleurs il peut par son
vote s'exprimer sur le projet européen
et la direction qu'il doit prendre et
c'est ce que les citoyens européens
feront de nouveau l'an prochain et il
détermineront par leur vote la direction
que doit prendre l'Europe
le drapeau européen le drapeau européen
est
identifié dans le monde entier et la
France dans ce projet politique inédit
porte une responsabilité majeure elle en
a été à l'avant-garde aussi aussi le
gouvernement donnera naturellement un
avis favorable à l'adoption de cette
proposition de loi je vous remercie je
vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur
Pierre-Alexandre Anglade président de la
commission des affaires européennes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues parce que l'Europe
est un projet politique elle est
porteuse de symboles le drapeau bleu au
12 au 12 étoiles en étain par tous les
Français comme l'héritage européen de
notre pays membres fondateur de l'Union
européenne parmi les 27 il est un
symbole de l'unité européenne de la
réconciliation après les milliers de
morts les souffrances les atrocités des
conflits qui déchirèrent les peuples
européens en
Ukraine en Moldavie en Géorgie il est
brandi lors des manifestations il
pavoisent les bâtiments officiels comme
à la Rada de Kiev jusque dans son
hémicycle il représente un espoir de
paix et de liberté pour des millions de
citoyens de ces pays l'Ukraine est
attaqué car elle a fait le choix avec la
révolution de maïdan de 2014 de se
tourner vers l'Europe elle est attaquée
pour ce qu'elle est un pays libre
démocratique et ouvert qui regarde vers
l'Union européenne et son drapeau la
Géorgie et la Moldavie sont déstabilisés
par les Russes pour les mêmes raisons
ces pays sont des cibles parce qu'ils
nous ressemblent parce qu'ils croient en
la démocratie libérale respectueuse de
l'individu des minorités des droits
fondamentaux et cette guerre en Ukraine
c'est déstabilisation au fond ce sont
des attaques contre les valeurs de
l'Europe contre ce qui fonde notre
identité d'Européen et ce n'est pas pour
rien si les Ukrainiens paroissent ce
drapeau dans toutes les rues du crâne
dans ces moments si singuliers chacun
ressent le changement d'époque que nous
sommes en train de vivre nous savons que
notre avenir en commun que notre
capacité à nous européen de défendre
notre modèle nos valeurs au fond ce qui
fait notre singularité dans ce siècle se
décide maintenant
nous soutenons l'Ukraine car l'agression
dont elle est victime en violation de
tous les fondements du droit
international est insupportable et que
la loi du plus fort ne saurait être
consacrée mais nous la soutenons aussi
car nous comprenons que nous ne sommes
pas capables de résister à ses côtés
alors nous perdrons tout ce que nous
avons construit depuis la fin de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale la liberté la
paix la sécurité pour les générations à
venir Poutine ne veut pas seulement
rayer l'Ukraine de la carte il veut
redéfinir à sa manière l'ordre de
sécurité en Europe ce moment de bascule
les dirigeants européens l'ont
parfaitement saisi là au Poutine espérer
la division il a trouvé un front uni là
où il pensait voir l'Europe se disloqué
il la voit se renforcer comme jamais
plus qu'un drapeau le drapeau européen
et le symbole de cette résistance et
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs dur
rassemblement national le sens et le
lien avec cette proposition de loi la
semaine passée
un responsable de l'extrême droite ça a
été rappelé par Madame la Ministre à
l'instant ne lui voyez ni symbole ni
histoire à ce drapeau européen hier
encore un 8 mai une responsable
politique de la France insoumise député
européenne de surcroît assimilé dans le
même élan europhobe le drapeau européen
à une forfaiture démocratique rappelons
l'heure que le drapeau européen est le
symbole de la paix de la liberté de
l'âme démocratie pour tous les peuples
du continent et qu'il ne replace aucun
drapeau national aucun drapeau français
ne sera remplacé par un drapeau européen
sur les frontons des mairies aucun
drapeau français et toutes celles et
ceux qui dans une espèce de duplicité
sans prennent avec autant de violence
autant de véhémence au drapeau européen
cash au fond mal leur cible leur cible
et la destruction et la déconstruction
du projet européen voilà ce qu'ils
veulent mettre à terre en s'en prenant
au drapeau européen en se faisant ils se
font les idiots utiles de pouvoir
autoritaire qui rêvent d'affaiblir
l'Europe et vous le et joue un jeu
dangereux car dans ce moment si
particulier que nous sommes en train de
vivre nous savons que l'Europe et notre
meilleur chance un levier de puissance
pour répondre aux grands défis que nous
sommes en train de vivre qu'aurait-on
fait sans l'Europe lors du covid c'est
grâce à elle que nous avons pu acheter
c'est grâce à elle que nous avons pu
acheter en commun les vaccins et de voir
et que voit l'extrême droite à ce
moment-là protester mais si nous vous
avions écouté Madame Le Pen nous aurions
les vaccins russes et si nous avions
écouté Monsieur Mélenchon nous aurions
des vaccins chinois ou des vaccins
cubains qu'aurait-on fait sans l'Europe
après la pandémie de covid c'est grâce à
elle et à son plan de relance que nous
avons pu éviter les faillites les 750
milliards d'euros que nous avons
emprunté en commun monsieur voilà la
meilleure réponse que nous avons apporté
aux Européens et à nos entreprises à nos
artisans à nos commerçants et à toutes
nos TPE à nos PME dans la majorité nous
continuerons de défendre l'Europe face à
ceux qui veulent la défaire et vous en
montrer encore aujourd'hui un exemple
parfait et le notre meilleur chance nous
avons toujours assumé porter défendu une
France forte dans une Europe souveraine
mais nous aurons aussi à l'affaire
évoluer c'est cela que nous porterons
dans les semaines et les mois à venir et
c'est aussi pour cela que nous défendons
le drapeau européen sur les frontons de
nos mairie je vous remercie
j'ai reçu de Madame Mathilde panot et
des membres du groupe la France
insoumise nouvelle union populaire
écologique et social une motion de rejet
préalable déposa en application de
l'article 91 alinéa 5 du règlement la
parole est à Monsieur Arnaud Le Gall
[Applaudissements]
la présidente
madame la ministre chers collègues
nous examinons aujourd'hui la
proposition de loi visant à rendre
obligatoire le pavoisement des drapeaux
françaises et européens sur le fronton
des mairies les drapeaux et l'Europe
sont des sujets sérieux j'y reviendrai
mais en pleine crise sociale et
politique il y avait des enjeux
plusieurs gens à traiter pour nos
concitoyens et concitoyennes vous avez
voulu encore une fois faire diversion
personne n'est dupe un grand quotidien
soucieux de la cohésion du bloc ne
libéral va jusqu'à citer des collègues
horizons ou modem évoquant je cite un
sujet complètement dehors des
préoccupations des Français et les
collègues Renaissance se plaignent du
fait que comme souvent l'objectif n'est
pas de légiférer mais de cliver et de
faire parler
tout le monde aura compris que ce projet
de loi n'a aucune utilité pratique
d'abord
la grande majorité des mairies de France
sont déjà pavoisées sans qui existent
quelconque obligation de le faire en
dehors de certaines journées symboliques
je me permets d'ajouter que l'amendement
que va soutenir notre collègue fait que
de toute façon ça doit changera rien à
la faire
vous venez d'exclure 90% des communes de
votre de votre du périmètre de votre loi
alors pourquoi ne pas laisser cette
liberté aux communes les maires qui pour
beaucoup se demandent comment ils vont
équilibrer leur prochain budget dès lors
que vous laissez les fournisseurs
d'énergie se gavés sur le de tout le
monde ont d'autres urgences à traiter
inversement quitte à rendre obligatoire
des symboles d'appartenance à la nation
française et Europe pourquoi ne pas
rendre également obligatoire
l'inscription de la devise spécifique à
la République liberté égalité fraternité
chers collègues vous faites là de bien
mauvais défenseur de la République
mais en vérité il ne s'agit pas pour
vous de débattre de la meilleure manière
d'articuler appartenance nationale et
appartenant sur européenne votre
objectif principal est de tenter de
camoufler la colère du peuple car oui le
sujet central de préoccupation des
Français des Françaises ce sont les deux
ans que vous voulez leur voler avec
votre réforme des retraites inutiles
antidémocratiques inégalitaire
mais vous me direz peut-être que votre
proposition renvoie l'actualité car la
crise actuelle a aussi un lien avec
l'Union européenne telle qu'elle est
en effet un des objectifs de votre
réforme des retraites et de souscrire
aux critères d'austéritaires que
Bruxelles impose avec votre plein accord
si je parle l'Union européenne telle
qu'elle est c'est à dire
fondamentalement néolibéral c'est parce
que jamais nous n'accepterons nous
n'accepterons le débat binaire que vous
tentez d'imposer avec vos gros sabots
il est écrit par avance que vous
repeindrez quiconque votre proposition
de loi en nationaliste bornée ou en
frexitter non non et non dès 1957 un
fervent partisan de la construction
européenne comme Pierre Mendès France
pouvait dans une un discours qui n'a pas
pris une ride regretté à cette même
tribune que rien ne soit envisagé pour
je cite la généralisation rapide des
avantages sociaux à l'intérieur de tous
les pays du marché commun afin d'éviter
une concurrence généralisée entre les
États membres il s'inquiétait de même de
la quasi disparition des protections
douanières nous exposant à une
concurrence déloyale enfin il craignait
que la libre circulation des capitaux
provoque une diminution des
investissements productifs non seulement
notre illustre prédécesseur avait vu
juste mais l'orientation européenne
contre laquelle il mettait en garde a
été mise en œuvre au-delà de tout ce
qu'il pouvait craindre
il n'y a donc pas d'un côté les
pro-européens ouverts et progressistes
que vous prétendez incarner et de
l'autre les anti-européens rabougris
nous nous serions indéniés avatar
un petit peu tu vas avoir la suite il y
a ceux dont nous faisons partie qui
milite avec des propositions maintes
fois exprimées pour une Europe faite de
solidarité entre les peuples
d'harmonisation sociale et fiscale
d'orientation des investissements vers
une planification industrielle et
écologique au service de la transition
énergétique et de l'indépendance
vis-à-vis des puissances comme la Chine
les États-Unis ou la Russie et il y a
ceux qui telent les cabris du général de
Gaulle invoque une Europe mythique pour
mieux masquer leur adhésion de fond à
l'Europe européenne telle qu'elle est à
l'Union européenne telle qu'elle est né
au libéral autoritaire atlantiste
vous aurez beau parler dans votre exposé
des motifs de promesses de paix de
prospérité de fraternité le réel vous
rattrapera s'agissant de la paix pour
être crédible vous auriez au moins pu
avoir la délicatesse d'interdire que des
fils dans Paris deux jours avant la
célébration de la victoire sur le
Troisième Reich des manifestants
affirmant néo-nazis affermant leur
nostalgie du nouvel ordre européen de
l'Asie
c'est ballot mais vous on va vous a pas
entendu sur le sujet il n'y a pas
ailleurs pas de paix durable sans
prospérité fraternité concrètement et
sans revenir sur l'ensemble des
politiques catastrophiques des dernières
décennies qu'a fait l'union pour les
faire avancer pendant et depuis la
pandémie de covid-19 elle a d'abord mis
en place un soi-disant plan de relance
qui n'en était pas en tout à fait pour
nourrir mais lisez les gens qui s'y
connaissent pour nourrir l'image de
grands sauveur de l'Europe qui décède de
vendre depuis 2017 et s'octroyer
d'appartenait de ce plan Emmanuel Macron
a cédé avaler sans discuter les critères
de compatibilité avec leur dos
libéralisme allemand au final un plan de
750 milliards très inférieurs aux pertes
subies au sein de l'Union pendant la
crise et alors qu'un pays comme les
États-Unis aligné des milliers de
milliards
un plan ne comportant ni conditionnalité
écologique et sociales ni investissement
pour gagner en indépendance énergétique
avant que l'on soit mise au pied du mur
un plan ne créant aucune ressource
supplémentaire en raison du refus de
taxer les très haut profits des
entreprises ou les transactions
financières j'ai faux
un plan dans la seule règle claire était
le retour annoncé à l'austérité une fois
passé la pandémie depuis 2022 alors que
la reprise économique est plus que
timide que la guerre sévit au port du
continent et que nous faisons face à une
inflation né des profils ont été de
profiteurs de guerre et de crise au
prétexte de lutter contre l'inflation la
Banque centrale européenne augmente les
taux d'intérêt
ce choix qui risque de créer une crise
économique majeure
ne répond rien à la nature d'une
inflation provoquée par une boucle
pénurie profit
cette politique monétaire ne sert qu'à
préserver les revenus du capital et
l'épargne accumulés par les plus aisés
aux dépens des travailleurs qui voient
chaque mois leur revenu renié par
laflation il ne s'agit pas pour la BCE
de lutter contre laflation mais de la
faire payer au plus modeste
enfin fin avril la Commission annoncée
sans que vous n'y trouviez quoi que ce
soit à redire le retour d'impact
budgétaire dont la règle des 3% a été en
son temps adopté sur un coin de table et
n'a aucune forme de pertinence
économique on connaît la suite déjà
annoncée au prétexte de respecter ses
règles vous allez détruire encore un peu
plus les services publics de santé
d'éducation de transport vous allez
continuer à privatiser ce qui est encore
privatisable vous allez encore rogner un
système de protection sociale qui fait
pourtant notre force et vous ne
programmerez pas les investissements
publics nécessaires à la transition
écologique entre autres
si on ne l'arrête pas la vis sans fin la
vie sera sans fin puisque cette bonne
politique affaiblit l'économie dont les
rentrés fiscales ce qui vous sert
ensuite à justifier toujours plus
d'austérité nos compatriotes ne
supportent plus cela vous le savez c'est
pourquoi vous préférez au débat concret
sur la politique européenne des
propositions métaphysiques sur les
symboles
ceci étant posé vous me direz que les
désaccords que nous pouvons avoir avec
le gouvernement de la République
française ne nous amène pas à
questionner le drapeau tricolore
c'est qu'il y a une différence
fondamentale chers collègues dans le cas
de l'Union le néolibéralisme n'est pas
un choix conjoncturel de tel ou tel
majorité le dogmatisme ayant été poussé
à l'extrême ce choix politique gravé
dans le marbre des traités européens
traiter eux-mêmes en théorie un des
boulonnable puisque comme l'avait dit
l'ancien président de la commission
Jean-Claude Juncker il ne peut y avoir
de choix démocratiques contre les
traités européens
de fait qui qu'on propose de ne pas
mentir aux Français donc de leur dire
que pour bâtir une Europe sociale il
faut impérativement désobéir au traités
est aussitôt classé comme anti-européen
dans votre vision binaire du monde
voir complotiste
pire les traités en vigueur sont issus
d'un piétinement de la souveraineté
populaire pour ne soutenir qu'aucun de
la France en 2005 le peuple français
arrosé par référendum le traité
constitutionnel européen
mais il lui a été imposé deux ans plus
tard avec un nouveau nom avec un nouveau
nom et dans une version à peine modifiée
à vous observer je comprends que vous
ayez d'autres préoccupations que
d'essayer de soigner une fracture
démocratique mais il y a 18 ans et qui
n'a cessé de s'aggraver depuis il
ignorait délétère
si vous voulez réconcilier le peuple
français avec l'Europe il faudra
d'autres mesures que d'imposer sur les
mairies un symbole d'appartenance à une
organisation sur la politique de
laquelle il n'a pas son mot à dire
quand elle existence d'un peuple
européen encore faudrait-il s'entendre
sur sa définition
pour nous dès lors qu'il s'agit de
décider de la chose commune le peuple se
définit avant tout comme le souverain un
acteur collectif dont les membres sont
reliés entre autres par l'exercice de
leur souveraineté par des mécanismes de
solidarité par une dans une certaine
mesure par des histoires partagées
pour la séverine est populaire c'est
déjà réglé dans l'Union actuelle elle
était étroitement limitée
la solidarité n'existe pas au quotidien
car votre Europe n'a cessé de mettre en
compétition les travailleurs entre eux
quant à l'histoire commune elle existe
inséparable des histoires nationales et
de l'histoire mondiale encore
faudrait-il ne pas la fantasmer ni la
réduire à des mythes et en toute état de
cause elle ne peut à elle seule suffir à
faire un peuple
alors évidemment quand on a aucun projet
fondé sur la souveraineté populaire à ce
à proposer ce qui reste en dernier
ressort c'est l'identité une
identité que vous pensez pouvoir tenir
sur un seul drapeau une
identité Rabou gris évanescente réduite
à des valeurs communes mobilisées au gré
des circonstances et que vous n'avez de
cesse de bafouer vous-même
dans ce contexte que peut faire un
drapeau si ce n'est masquer le désastre
annoncé
alors reste paraît-il l'autonomie
stratégique chère au président Macron
autrement dit la souveraine autrement
dit la souveraineté sans les peuples
mais voilà encore un objectif
inatteignable dans le cadre des traités
actuels a supposer qu'on puisse
surmonter les entreadismes qui dicte les
politiques extérieures des États membres
comment voulez-vous bâtir une autonomie
stratégique sans politique industrielle
dans des domaines de pointe ce manque
qui découle encore une fois des dogmes
qui corset l'Union aboutit à des
aberrations
commentez vous parler de souveraineté
européenne lorsque par exemple la banque
centrale choisie Amazon pour la phase
test des moyens de paiement de l'euro
numérique une décision scandaleuse selon
l'ancien directeur de l'Agence nationale
de sécurité des systèmes d'information
que j'avais d'interroger à ce sujet en
commission
comment faire croire en la possibilité
d'une Europe de la défense autonome
quand l'inscription dans le cadre de
l'OTAN est gravé dans le marbre des
traités vous pouvez considérer selon
nous à tort qu'on ne peut pas se
défendre sans l'OTAN mais alors soyez
cohérent et dites ce qu'il en coûte car
il est mensongé de prétendre que le
dodomie est possible dans ce cadre toute
l'histoire depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale le démontre
l'indépendance de l'Europe vis-à-vis de
la Chine de la Russie des États-Unis
suppose un minima une politique
industrielle énergétique ambitieuse
pilotée par la puissance publique elle
implique d'en finir avec la crurance
concurrence de tous contre tous au sein
de l'Union européenne elle-même elle ne
saurait advenir sans la mise en place de
mesures réelles de protectionnisme
écologique et social à l'échelle de
l'Union bref autant d'objectifs
rigoureusement incompatibles avec les
traités actuels accepter de débat d'une
révision sérieuse de ces traités de la
manière dont la France pays contribuer
et nous accepterons de prendre sérieux
vos propositions en attendant ces noms
et nous proposons via cette motion de
rejet de gagner un temps précieux je
vous remercie
je vous remercie
madame la ministre je vais répondre
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre c'est à vous
[Musique]
merci merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Député monsieur
le président de commission monsieur le
rapporteur et Monsieur le Député Le Gall
mesdames et messieurs les députés
vous avez parlé d'une organisation dans
lequel le peuple n'a pas son mot à dire
mais allez dire donc cela on sait plus
de 700 députés européens qui vont qui
sont élus et qui vont l'être de nouveau
en 2024
vous avez au sujet de l'Europe à peu
près énumériques tout ce que votre
novembre contient de mots
néolibéral Atlantis totoritaire hors de
libéraliste c'est le bréviaire de
l'anti-européaniste
quel remaniement mais quel reniement de
ce que la France grande nation
européenne
a pu bâtir pour garantir la paix et la
prospérité sur notre continent
[Musique]
si vous voulez bien m'écouter comme j'ai
eu la politesse de le faire je vous mets
en garde sur ce que représente les
positions des deux extrêmes de cette
hémicycle
un danger pour la France
un danger pour le projet européen un
danger pour l'avenir de nos enfants
et oui et oui il est beau goût plus
facile de proclamer le grand soir que de
travailler avec assiduité et sans
relâche comme le président le fait
depuis 2017 à transformer l'Europe
à la rendre plus efficace plus
démocratique plus Unies plus à même de
peser de toute son influence pour
protéger les Européens et les Français
alors vous avez parlé du quotidien le
rap de la santé face à la pandémie
l'Europe unie a su prendre les
dispositions fortes et rapides pour
protéger les plus rafragiques l'Europe
économique face à la crise économique le
rapporteur l'a rappelé nous avons
mobilisé un plan de relance européen
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
l'Europe d'une envergure inédite pour
accompagner les entreprises les
commerces de proximité l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
l'Europe de la défense face à la guerre
aux portes de l'Union européenne nous
avons apporté une réponse humaine
humanitaire militaire financière dans
des records et poser les fondations de
l'Europe de la défense l'Europe
écologique face à la crise climatique
c'est l'Europe qui aujourd'hui affiche
la plus grande ambition de toutes les
régions du monde
au quotidien
au quotidien les politiques européennes
contribuent au mieux vivre de l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens la Pâques près de 60
milliards la garantie de salaire minimum
nous l'avons fait pendant la présidence
française l'encadrement des plateformes
nous le faisons la protection des
données personnelles la lutte contre la
déforestation la mobilité étudiante et
celle des apprentis un autre texte que
vous aurez à débat de ce soir vous
parlez nous faisons voilà ce que vous
promettez de détricoter de déconstruire
d'abolir en surjourant les effares quand
on vous propose d'afficher un drapeau
européen
le président Giscard d'Estaing disait
l'Europe c'est une grande réussite et
c'est ce qui irrite et bien c'est bien
ce que nous voyons ce soir vous en êtes
arrivés à un tel degré de détestation
que vous proposez d'emblée un rejet
préalable sans débat mais nous sommes
ici pour débattre
[Applaudissements]
alors le débat vous fait-il peur
à nouveau je reprends les mots de la
sénatrice écologiste Mélanie Vogel face
au tweet Manon Brie sérieusement et
naturellement mon avis est défavorable
sur cette notion de rejet préalable je
vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente moi quand
j'ai vu qu'il y avait une motion de
rejet sur cette proposition de loi je me
suis dit qu'après tout ce sujet n'était
peut-être pas aussi symbolique que
d'aucun voudrait bien le faire croire et
pas aussi anecdotique mais surtout quand
j'ai vu motion de rejet je me suis dit
où est votre émotion de projet mes chers
collègues quel est votre projet
alternatif
la vérité mes chers collègues c'est que
votre projet alternatif c'est un projet
de replie nationaliste qui est
exactement la même chose que ce que
propose vos collègues d'extrême droite
voilà ce que vous proposez mais surtout
vous avez dit Monsieur Le Gall cette
proposition elle vit d'en faire à faire
parler mais je comprends si vous
souffrez madame si vous souffrez qu'on
puisse parler d'Europe calmement s'il
vous plaît
madame madame s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît
moi je regrette monsieur le gars vous
avez dit une chose qui est extrêmement
intéressante vous avez dit les citoyens
européens ils n'ont pas voir au chapitre
mais quelle insulte pour le président
Giscard d'Estaing quelle insulte pour
tous nos parlementaires européens
quelles conception avez-vous de la
citoyenneté européenne mais où est passé
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui votait en faveur
du traité de Maastricht traité de
Maastricht qui a institué la citoyenneté
européenne mes chers collègues vous vous
perdez mais surtout Monsieur Le Gall
vous nous avez dit une chose très
intéressante vous nous avez dit vous
voulez parler oui nous voulons parler
d'Europe et pourquoi nous voulons parler
d'Europe et je comprends que vous n'ayez
aucune envie de parler d'Europe parce
que votre projet qui est un projet de
frexit masqué vous avez de plus en plus
de mal à le défendre et à le faire
comprendre aux Français il y a 10 ans
comme Madame Le Pen vous étiez pour une
sortie de l'Union européenne aujourd'hui
vous êtes pour une sortie des traités
que vous n'arriverez jamais à mettre en
œuvre parce que avec votre victoire à
l'élection présidentielle vous allez
arriver devant nos partenaires européens
et leur dire nous sommes la France nous
allons faire comme ça
et vous allez nous suivre mais c'est une
conception des règles européennes de
l'unanimité et de la solidarité entre
les nations que personne ne connaît mes
chers collègues votre projet la vraie
forfaiture démocratique c'est la vôtre
c'est celle par laquelle vous mentez aux
Français et vous mentez sur ce que vous
voulez pour l'Union européenne est-ce
que vous voulez pour eux pour ces
raisons il faut évidemment rejeter cette
notion de rejet je vous remercie
sur le vote de la motion de rejet
préalable je suis saisie par le groupe
Renaissance le groupe rassemblement
national le groupe la France insoumise
une demande de scrutin public le scrutin
est annoncé dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée nationale
nous passons s'il vous plaît maintenant
et dans le calme vous explications de
vote deux minutes par groupe nous
commençons avec Monsieur Pradal du
groupe horizon
allez-y monsieur Pradal madame la
Présidente
la paix mondiale ne saurait être
sauvegardée sur des efforts créateurs à
la mesure des dangers qu'il a menace
c'est par ces mots que s'ouvre la
déclaration de Robert Schuman du 9 mai
1950 il fallait le rappeler la motion de
rejet préalable qui nous est proposée
faite et prévu dans deux cas soit en
raison de l'inconstitutionnalité d'un
texte ce n'est pas le cas et ça donne
d'ailleurs pas été évoqué soit lorsqu'il
n'y aurait pas lieu à délibérer nous
pensons au sein du groupe horizon et à
parenté qu'il y a lieu de libérer parce
que nous voulons examiner ce texte nous
voulons examiner les amendements qui ont
été déposés par l'ensemble des groupes
parce que nous voulons parler d'Europe
c'est pour cela que nous voterons
résolument contre cette motion de rejet
préalable je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur reberrot du groupe Renaissance
[Musique]
parce que tout simplement ça a été dit
d'ailleurs par notre collègue nous aussi
nous voulons le débat sur la place du
drapeau national du drapeau européen de
l'attachement aux valeurs de la France
et de l'Europe l'Europe composée de
nations démocratique et prise de liberté
de dialogue de respect des droits de
l'homme bref évidemment nous voterons
contre et nous remercions déjà tous ceux
qui souhaiteront comme nous le débat ce
soir et qui souhaiteront parler Europe
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Tanguy du groupe rassemblement
national
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre madame présidente
évidemment nous voterons pour le rejet
pour qu'il n'y ait pas de débat car il
n'y a pas de débat avoir car les
Français ont eu ce débat et ils ont dit
non vous êtes chers collègues ici par la
seule volonté du peuple vous êtes ici
par la seule volonté du peuple et vous
n'avez jamais eu le mandat pour défaire
ce que le peuple a fait ce que le peuple
français a fait par référendum seul le
peuple le faire par référendum vous
n'avez jamais eu ce pouvoir et vous ne
l'aurez jamais
vous ne faites jamais rien au hasard et
si malgré le vote des Français vous avez
imposé dans nos rues dans nos mairies
sur mes ministères dans cette hémicycle
derrière le président de la République
ce drapeau contre la volonté du peuple
c'est que vous méprisez le peuple
français vous le méprisez et à chaque
fois que vous apparaissez d'ailleurs ce
drapeau vous affirmez votre mépris mais
qu'est-ce que vous avez encore comme
respect du peuple français en macronie
pour imposer contre la volonté du peuple
ce qu'il a refusé que vous le vouliez ou
non les Français ne partagent pas votre
rêve d'étouffer les nations il le
partageront jamais il n'y a que trois
couleurs trois couleurs face auxquelles
les Français s'inclinent devant leur
mort dans leur école dans nos cérémonies
le blanc le bleu le blanc et le rouge
il n'y a
il n'y a aucun symbole aucun symbole
dans votre bleu dans votre 12 étoiles
vous-même vous ne savez pas d'où qui
viennent vous justifiez le passé par le
présent depuis quand lorsqu'il futon un
symbole censé être raciné dans le passé
par le présent ça n'a aucun sol le blanc
notre blanc c'est 1000 ans d'histoire
éternelle de la France c'est le manteau
des églises c'est l'étincelante lumière
de la Révolution le rouge et les Bleus
c'est le peuple de Paris uni symbolisé
dans la grande révolution qui à travers
le temps et l'espace symbolise pour
l'éternité le peuple de France je vous
remercie
[Musique]
la parole est à Madame Garrido du groupe
la France insoumise s'il vous plaît
collègue il faut rejeter cette
proposition de loi car il faut avoir
l'humilité collègue
ayez l'humilité de comprendre lorsque
notre place ici à l'Assemblée nationale
n'est pas de contredire l'expression
démocratique des Français il est rare
que nous soyons saisis de sujets dont
les Français ont eu proprement la
possibilité de s'exprimer par référendum
c'est le cas de ce qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
parce que naturellement et par coutume
et par consentement et paradisions ils y
adèrent c'est comme ça que l'on procède
dans les sociétés démocratiques l'esprit
républicain c'est de comprendre que dans
notre Constitution nous parlons du
drapeau bleu blanc rouge nous parlons de
la devise Liberté Égalité Fraternité
nous parlons du principe le gouvernement
du peuple par le peuple pour le peuple
rien de tout ceci n'est obligé les
Français il y a d'air ils courent devant
il le protège même dans leur
manifestation et dans leurs expressions
voilà ce que vous devriez faire si vous
étiez réellement démocrate et européen
vous n'imposerez pas l'Europe par la
discipline vous l'imposerez par la
liberté de l'adhésion la libre la libre
adhésion des consciences des Français
c'est ça qui compte vous dites l'Europe
c'est la démocratie et bien soyez
démocrates jusqu'au bout des ondes comme
nous le sommes en France rejetez cette
loi qui est inutile et agressive
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Gosselin du
groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ce qui devrait nous unir les
couleurs de la République
reconnu par la convention le 15 février
parce que la majorité a voulu yadjointe
d'autres éléments en réalité aujourd'hui
nous divise nous divise dans un débat
électrique qui va sembler bien pitoyable
je répète pitoyable à nos concitoyens
ils vont le trouver et pitoyable parce
que notre dapperon notre drapeau est
honorable
c'est dans le drapeau français
que l'on met les morts pour la
République c'est dans le drapeau
français que l'on rend hommage aux
soldats morts pour la France c'est le
drapeau français qui recouvre certains
cercueils
le drapeau européen peut peut-être
trouver sa place dans le débat mais pas
sous cette forme là et vous éloignez
malheureusement un débat qui pourtant
est important nous nous étripons sur les
drapeaux
pour autant et j'y reviendrai dans la
discussion générale tout à l'heure
peut-être pouvons-nous nous retrouver je
ne le sais en tout cas il n'est pas
question à ce stade de diviser davantage
et il faut que le débat puisse se
poursuivre que les uns et les autres
puissent donner leurs arguments et nous
espérons nous espérons qu'à la fin de ce
débat qui paraîtra bien illégitime et
long nous pourrons nous retrouver nous
faisons ce pari nous faisons ce pari aux
républicains de nous retrouver derrière
le drapeau de la République
autour de sa devise de liberté d'égalité
et de fraternité je vous appelle donc au
consensus autour de nos valeurs
républicaines et des valeurs
la parole est à Monsieur Balanant du
groupe démocrate
merci Madame ma présidente évidemment il
faut que nous ayons ce débat et le début
de cette séance le montre il y a j'ai
envie de dire deux façons de voir le
sujet il y a les gens qui sont
pro-européens qui sont heureux de cette
construction européenne et il y a les
autres et il y a les autres d'un côté le
RN avec cette diatribble de Monsieur
Tanguy où on aura compris cette haine
viscérale de la construction européenne
cette haine viscérale quelques jours
quelque part de la paix tout simplement
parce que rappelons-le
rappelons-le c'est quoi l'Europe
l'Europe c'est la paix
cette construction européenne c'est la
paix et de l'autre côté on aura Monsieur
Le Gall je n'ai pas vraiment compris
Monsieur Le Gall et je n'ai pas compris
et c'est pour ça que nous devons avoir
le débat je n'ai pas compris votre
position
au-delà de la question du drapeau que
vous soyez en opposition politique
idéologique sur le modèle européen
actuel et sur le modèle politique
européen certes mais est-ce que le
drapeau européen et le symbole de cette
non le symbole non donc vous êtes vous
êtes je vous le dis messieurs les
insoumis à côté de la plaque Vous vous
opposez au drapeau européen parce que
vous vous opposez à la construction
européenne tout simplement
parce que si vous aimiez la construction
européenne vous aimeriez le drapeau
européen comme on peut être français ne
pas être d'accord avec le président
Macron et aimer le drapeau français donc
nous avons besoin d'avoir ce débat nous
avons besoin d'aller jusqu'au bout de la
démarche pour que les masques tombent ce
soir je vous remercie nous allons donc
maintenant procéder au scrutin je vais
donc mettre au voile à la motion de
rejet préalable je vous prie de bien
vouloir gagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 299
exprimé 282 majorité 142 pour 121
corrompre 161 l'Assemblée nationale n'a
pas adopté
nous allons passer maintenant à la
discussion générale
je vous remercie de sortir rapidement
pour ce qu'il souhaite
[Musique]
donc nous allons commencer avec Monsieur
Pradal du groupe horizon
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers
le drapeau tricolore est un symbole de
la République française comme l'a dit
Lamartine la France et le drapeau
tricolore c'est une même pensée un même
prestige une même terreur au besoin pour
nos ennemis
il symbolise l'unité de notre nation à
ses côtés le drapeau de l'Union
européenne fort de ces 12 étoiles dorées
sur fond bleu rappelle l'unité la
solidarité et l'harmonie entre les
peuples européens
l'importance des symboles justement à
nourrit nos débats en commission des
lois la semaine dernière et la date
d'aujourd'hui Journée de l'Europe est
également symbolique et donc bien placé
pour l'examen de ce texte au-delà du
drapeau l'objet le sujet de cette
journée et bien l'avènement sur notre
continent de la paix qu'il nous faut
plus que jamais défendre le groupe
Horizon est apparenté soutiendra cette
proposition de loi
parce que d'abord nous sommes
profondément convaincus que les symboles
nationaux permet de renforcer l'unité de
la nation en construisant une mémoire et
une histoire commune le symbole de
Marianne comme le drapeau tricolore sont
intrinsèquement liés à la Révolution et
accompagne l'émergence de la nation
républicaine ils incarnent notre
histoire et forment la base de notre
culture commune il nous paraît pertinent
de prévoir ce pavoisement sur l'ensemble
des
34955 mairies françaises si le symbole
de la présence de l'État dans les
territoires et de notre attachement à
une histoire partagée ensuite nous
sommes profondément attachés à la
construction européenne les 12 étoiles
du drapeau qui représentent le mouvement
dans la stabilité son terriblement
d'actualité
l'unité des peuples européens et chaque
jour plus déterminante à l'heure où la
guerre est à nos portes le drapeau
européen symbolise une Europe souveraine
unie et démocratique que nous devons
nous appeler à protéger à développer et
à chérir car ces larmes la plus
puissante dont nous disposions face au
défi de demain
nous étonnons donc de certains
amendements qui tout en souhaitant
l'installation du drapeau français sur
les préfectures commissariat caserne et
autres bâtiments publics veulent exclure
le drapeau européen dans cette hémicycle
les débats sont vifs sur la position
adoptée par rapport au projet européens
au sujet de l'existence même de l'Europe
et de son drapeau sans entrer dans les
Corrèzes internes je tiens cependant à
souligner que la démocratie n'est la
propriété de personnes ici cependant il
nous appartient à tous de protéger nos
biens communs les plus précieux la
liberté et la paix
finalement la force du symbole et de se
passer de mots ce double pavoisement
reflète notre fidélité à notre histoire
et notre volonté d'un avenir commun oui
c'est l'Europe depuis l'Atlantique
jusqu'à l'Oural c'est l'Europe c'est
toute l'Europe qui décidera du destin du
monde Adil général de Gaulle nombre de
nos compatriotes ont dû se battre pour
défendre les valeurs incarnées par le
drapeau tricolore et celui de l'Europe
incarne la paix que le génie des peuples
européens a su construire sans reniement
appelons toutefois l'attention du
Gouvernement sur ce coup important que
peuvent représenter l'achat et
l'installation de ses drapeaux pour
certaines communes notamment les plus
petites contraint par les règles de
recevabilité des amendements nous ne
pouvons que demander un rapport sur ce
sujet ce sera l'objet de notre unique
amendement mais assistant en faveur d'un
financement par l'état de ce dispositif
le groupe Horizon est apparenté votre à
cette proposition de loi et espère que
le gouvernement donnera les moyens aux
mères de répondre à cet appel
républicain je vous remercie
merci
la parole est à Monsieur jérémyordanov
du groupe écologiste
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur chers
République accueille ces jours-ci à un
théâtre bien curieux
on y trouve un président sans peuple
on y observe un gouvernement sans projet
les quelques badauds qui s'attardent
peuvent même apercevoir une majorité
sans majorité
et une troupe de députés
subordonnée inapte à faire tomber un
exécutif qui ne rend pourtant plus
compte à personne
c'est dans ce paysage en déliquescence
que le groupe Renaissance a eu cette
ingénieuse idée que de nous faire
parlementer sur les drapeaux
faut-il en rire faut-il en pleurer nul
ne sait à l'extérieur le monde tourne
alors pour vous distraire de cette
tragi-comédie franco-française donc il
le faut bien le reconnaître nous sommes
tous un peu là
laissez-moi planter le décor de l'Europe
que nous voulons nous écologistes
nous voulons une Europe qui met en place
une économie sobre adaptée aux
ressources de notre continent aux
limites planétaires et qui mettent un
terme à l'effondrement de la
biodiversité nous voulons une Europe qui
soit solide et volontaire pour défendre
l'État de droit et les libertés
fondamentales face aux réactionnaires
aux îles libéraux au xénophobe qui nous
menacent de l'extérieur comme de
l'intérieur
nous voulons une Europe humaniste et
accueillante qui garantissent la dignité
des personnes nous voulons une Europe
qui préviennent et réparent les
injustices sociales qui redistribuent
les richesses nous voulons une
intégration fiscale pour éviter les
logiques de dumping entre les États
membres nous voulons une Europe qui met
fin au paradis fiscaux nous voulons une
Europe qui accompagne nos paysans vers
une agriculture qui protège notre
environnement et qui assure notre
souveraineté alimentaire nous voulons
une Europe qui relocalise ses industries
et qui assurent notre indépendance
énergétique c'est une question de
souveraineté c'est aussi une question de
responsabilité externaliser les coûts
sociaux et environnementaux n'est pas
une solution
nous voulons une défense européenne pour
faire face aux mutations profondes de
l'ordre géopolitique mondial nous
voulons une diplomatie européenne
puissante puissante pour promouvoir
notre culture et nos valeurs pour
assurer la paix et la stabilité dans le
monde nous voulons enfin une Europe
populaire une Europe politique
démocratique nous voulons une Europe
fédérale alors c'est vrai nous n'avons
pas l'Europe que nous voulons du moins
celle-ci n'est pas achevée
mais nous avons déjà l'Union européenne
c'est beaucoup et les choses avancent je
disais nous n'avons pas l'Europe que
nous voulons mais nous n'avons pas non
plus la France que nous voulons
et nous aimons pourtant la France nous
aimons la France et nous aimons l'Europe
il faut des actes pour le dire
surtout des actes faut-il aussi des
drapeaux
qu'est-ce qu'un drapeau c'est un signe
d'attachement de ralliement accrochons
accroché sur le fronton de nos mairies
les bannières françaises européennes
c'est reconnaître que l'histoire nous
lie intimement c'est prendre conscience
et affirmer que nos valeurs sont
communes c'est clamer haut éclair que
nous partageons le même avenir
ma voisine au mairie les couleurs de la
France et de celle de l'Europe c'est
proclamée que nous sommes citoyens
français ces proclamé que nous sommes
citoyens européens
je conclurai en disant que si légiférer
sur la question des drapeaux ne saurait
suffire en aucune manière
à faire une politique forte et
ambitieuse ni pour la France ni pour
l'Europe les écologistes voteront
exprimerons dans leur vote leur
indéfectible attachement à la
construction européenne je vous remercie
je vous remercie
man du groupe Gauche démocrate et
républicaine
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre
le congéder a été clair sous sa position
Commission en aucun cas nous n'avons
dans l'idée de rejeter l'héritage
révolutionnaire de la France ou encore
de remettre en cause le projet européen
mais l'intérêt même de cette proposition
de loi nous paraît bien ébuleux et son
existence est en elle-même un aveu
d'incohérence de la part de la majorité
présidentielle d'un côté nous avons un
président de la République qui onit
l'empilement législatif et qui est allé
jusqu'à estimer il y a quelques semaines
de cela que nous passons trop souvent
par la loi de l'autre côté nous avons
une majorité présidentielle qui cherche
à apparaître comme plus Eurofil que Jean
monnaie et qui propose pour cela une loi
qui non seulement veut qu'on traîne les
maires à respecter une pratique il est
déjà par une grande majorité d'entre eux
mais qui en plus leur coûterait des sous
dans un contexte de finances locales
déjà tendu
monsieur Castaner alors ministère de
l'Intérieur avait lui-même considéré
dans une réponse écrite de 2019 que le
principe de libre administration des
collectivités leur garanties de pouvoir
librement organiser le pavoisement des
édifices leur appartenant ce dispositif
équilibré confère au pavoisement une
valeur commémorative et honorifique
qu'il convient de préserver en une
banalisant pas
4 ans plus tard retournement de veste on
est obligatoire le pavoisement des
édifices publics ne viendrait plus en
banaliser l'aspect commémoratif et
honorifique mais finalement il s'agira
en fait d'un homogénéiser la pratique
sur le territoire national
avant de se parmi d'admiration devant le
drapeau européen et de l'afficher à
toutes les sauces sur nos bâtiments
publics commençons peut-être à respecter
la règle communautaire plutôt qu'en
multiplier les violations d'enchaîner
les condamnations par les instances
européennes
par ailleurs rappelons également que
l'eurocepticisme va croissant au sein de
la population et que cette distance et
que cette défiance qui prend en
puissance est avant tout la conséquence
de mesure qui ont été imposées par la
voix parlementaire à une population qui
n'avait justement rien demandé la
contrainte n'a jamais été rassemblueuse
et imposer ce double paroissement
permanent contreviendrait sans aucun
doute au but premier de l'acte de
pavoisier à savoir manifester de manière
démonstrative et symbolique une joie une
fierté un honneur par ailleurs j'ai noté
avec surprise que pour une fois l'exposé
des motifs mentionne expressément les
collectivités à statut particulier
ce qui est certainement une manière
détournée mais tout de même indéléka de
manifester une opposition aux velléité
autonomiste de voir indépendantiste
ainsi que l'élection récente Polynésie a
pu nous le démontrer d'une majorité des
territoires dit d'outre-mer
pourtant à l'image du drapeau tricolore
et du drapeau européen les drapeaux
régionaux ne font pas non plus l'objet
d'une législation c'est ainsi que l'État
français ne reconnaît pas officiellement
cette pratique mais ne l'interdit pas
non plus j'en profite donc pour vous
proposer d'aller plus loin encore dans
cette volonté affichée de pallier vide
juridique en matière de paroissement et
dacter la possibilité pour les
collectivités d'imposer leur drapeau
régionaux je vous remercie
je vous remercie et la parole est à
Monsieur Paul Molac pour le groupe
liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoires
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre bon madame la ministre pardon
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues donc en ce 9 mai Journée de
l'Europe je tiens à commencer à efferves
l'attachement de notre groupe à la
construction européenne et à ses valeurs
je note que depuis 70 ans il n'y a pas
eu de guerre majeure sur le continent
alors que il faut bien avouer que
c'était l'une de nos activités favorites
à peu près tous les 20 ans à chaque
génération
l'Europe nous a permis de vivre en paix
ce n'est pas la moindre des choses pour
autant
si notre groupe a toujours souhaité une
Europe au service des peuples de la
subsidiarité de l'innovation de la
croissance durable de l'emploi de la
compétitivité une Europe qui s'attaque
au dumping fiscaux sociaux et écologique
ainsi qu'à la fraude et à l'évasion
fiscale une Europe qui protège nos
économies nos concitoyens
et qu'il une Europe qui les reconnaît
dans sa diversité
il y a effectivement du travail alors le
groupe Renaissance aurait pu proposer un
texte sur ces sujets texte qui aurait pu
renforcer notre participation concrète à
l'Union européenne il a proposé une loi
dont l'ambition est relativement limitée
je le dis sans détour notre groupe a un
peu de mal à voir l'intérêt et l'utilité
d'un tel texte notre ordre du jour
est-il si vite qu'il soit nécessaire de
le combler à coup de proposition de loi
symbolique
ce ne sont pourtant pas les sujets qui
manquent sur lesquels nous se
concitoyens ne cesse nous alerter entre
les déserts médicaux l'adaptation au
changement climatique le problème du
logement qui est très grave dans toutes
les régions touristiques le renforcement
démocratique de nos institutions les
auteurs de cette proposition affirment
qu'il permettra de renforcer
l'attachement des citoyens à l'Union
européenne
ce n'est pas forcément avec un drapeau
que cela va se faire je continue à
croire que c'est l'exemplarité de notre
action qui nourrira l'attachement au
pays à l'Europe le simple fait de
déployer un drapeau sur le fronton d'une
mairie ne nous fera pas sentir plus
européen ou plus français nous avons
trois principales réserves sur ce texte
d'abord sur le portée du dispositif
soyons honnêtes la présence des travaux
turc tricolore sur le fronton de nos
mairies comme sur l'ensemble de nos
bâtiments publics et déjà
largement répondu
si j'ai bien quelques mérites ils n'ont
pas en permanence c'est plus souvent par
souci d'économie qu'autre chose
aussi cette proposition de loi
vous enfoncez un peu une porte ouverte
donc parfois les mairies qui ont
suffisamment d'argent chez nous c'est
pas compliqué il y a le drapeau de la
commune par exemple à
le drapeau breton le drapeau français et
le drapeau européen 4 et on n'aura pas
demandé d'en faire j'ai bien une commune
ou effectivement il y en a pas toujours
mais c'est une commune de 110 habitants
et effectivement chaque sous compte
donc
si vous voulez je vois pas trop
l'intérêt alors nous avons des collègues
qui vont aussi certainement parler de
leur drapeau régional ou de leur drapeau
de leur alors je pense évidemment elle
est
le drapeau basque
chirignyaki je pense aussi au drapeau
occitan pense à celui des Alsaciens et
bien sûr on a pour breton alors je sais
que notre ami et le drapeau normand bien
sûr
car on voit bien que finalement c'est
l'histoire de drapeau c'est quelque
chose aussi qui nous rappelle la mémoire
et c'est vrai que quelquefois notre
mémoire est le drapeau que l'on peut
avoir et bien nous rappelle parfois des
souvenirs
disons pas forcément très agréable bon
je vais prendre des exemples quand vous
êtes à La Rochelle par exemple de quoi
vous parle-t-on bah du siège de La
Rochelle bien sûr quand vous êtes dans
les semaines vous parle de quoi des
dragonnades quand vous êtes dans en
Vendée on vous parle évidemment des
exactions des colonnes infernales donc à
chaque fois chacun met derrière ce
drapeau ce qu'il veut y mettre mais
quelquefois sa propre mémoire car si on
nous a appris une histoire bien calibrée
quant aux étions à l'école je peux vous
dire que chacun la revoit en fonction de
son territoire et donc c'est là où
quelquefois la chose peut être délicate
et c'est pour ça que je pense que si on
en met un et bien il faut tous les
mettre de façon à n'avoir pas de
problème avec cela
c'est un conseil que je donne ce texte
s'inscrit aussi dans une logique que les
élus locaux peuvent prendre de façon
diverse certains nous diront mais oui je
le mets le drapeau français vous avez
quand même pas besoin de me dire ce
qu'il faut que je fasse c'est ce qu'on
dit certains mères donc on voit bien que
derrière c'est injonction peut-être
prise comme quelque part leur dire ce
qu'ils ont à faire et un regard sur leur
politique publique ça peut être mal vu
et ma dernière réserve évidemment
c'était sur le coup parce que un drapeau
ça peut valoir cher j'ai déjà vu des
drapeaux français où le rouge a disparu
il ne reste plus que le bleu et le blanc
pourquoi parce que ça va relativement
vite et ça se détruit relativement
rapidement quand on les laisse je vous
remercie de votre
vous comprenez nos réserves sur ce texte
merci
la parole est à Monsieur rebey Road pour
le groupe Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur cher Mathieu
chers collègues cette proposition est
importante à plus d'un titre et nous y
serons naturellement favorables d'abord
elle donne un cadre légal au pavoisement
bleu blanc rouge de nos mairies et je
l'espère également de nos sièges de
conseil régionaux départementaux ou
d'intercommunalité bref partout s'exerce
le pouvoir démocratique et républicain
au sein de nos collectivités
territoriales nous rejoignons ainsi la
pratique de très nombreux pays et nous
comblons un vide juridique en effet la
loi avait rendu obligatoire ce cadre
légal pour les établissements scolaires
et d'apprentissage
on aurait pu penser que les US
écoutument suffisent mais quand je vois
que certains peuvent faire dans notre
émission
tout ce qu'il faut pour détourner notre
hymne national lui aussi inscrit à
l'article 2 de la Constitution et
l'utiliser pour faire taire le
gouvernement et saboter les débats je me
dis que partout et toujours il faut
conforter la République et la démocratie
c'est le premier sens de ce texte
renforcer nos institutions républicaines
le second sens c'est de rappeler que
notre drapeau est le symbole de notre
souveraineté d'où sa place d'honneur et
que notre souveraineté s'incarne aussi
aujourd'hui dans une construction
commune celle du Conseil de l'Europe et
de l'Union européenne qui ont choisi un
drapeau commun le choix de ce texte le 9
mai Journée de l'Europe 73 ans après
l'appel de Robert Schuman coécrit avec
Jean Monnet n'est donc pas fortuit mais
est fort au sens politique au sens noble
du terme politique
fidèle à notre Constitution aux articles
2 et 88 notre emblème national en place
d'honneur doit être accompagnée par le
drapeau européen comme ça d'ailleurs le
cas dans notre hémicycle dernière madame
la Présidente comme ce fut le cas pour
la photographie officielle du président
Sarkozy pour la première fois n'oublions
jamais l'origine de notre construction
européenne et de ses symboles elle vient
des deux conflits mondiaux nés en Europe
qui ont ravagé notre continent par deux
fois au siècle dernier l'Union
européenne c'est 70 ans de paix sur
notre continent entre les pays qui ont
rejoint l'Union c'est d'abord cela la
construction européenne on peut toujours
faire la fine bouche mais nos
générations peuvent dire un grand merci
au Père fondateurs du Mouvement européen
aux pères fondateur de l'Europe et
saluer tous ceux qui constituent tous
ceux qui continuent cette œuvre elle
vient des camps de concentration et
d'extermination du plus jamais cela qui
ne fut jamais et c'est important de le
rappeler ici un point de détails de
l'histoire mais témoignent que la
barbarie est toujours possible au cœur
de notre civilisation de toutes
civilisation elle vient de femmes et
d'hommes meurtri de Conrad and hower
asimonvale qui ont porté une Europe des
nations démocratiques une construction
commune et une souveraineté partagée
afin d'éviter de nouvelles guerres et là
encore nous leur devons notre
reconnaissance c'est ce que nous
rappelle nos amis Ukrainiens qui ne
rêvent au fond que d'une chose c'est de
rejoindre cette Europe là pour échapper
au diktates de ceux Poutine en tête qui
n'accepte ni la démocratie ni la liberté
des peuples à disposer d'eux-mêmes ni
les droits de l'homme et du citoyen
cette souveraineté partagée c'est
d'abord celle de la paix de la
démocratie et des droits de l'homme que
nous Ré affirmons ici à travers le
drapeau européen aux côtés de ce qui
constitue notre identité forte celui de
la France je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est un monsieur Kevin préfère
pour le groupe rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues nous sommes en mai 2023
les Français sont toujours mobilisés
contre votre injuste et inutile réforme
des retraites l'inflation en particulier
l'inflation alimentaire reste hors de
contrôle les Français nous interpellent
tous tous les jours sur leur difficulté
à remplir leur panier de course les plus
précaires dans nos étudiants sautent des
repas le déficit commercial de notre
pays est historiquement haut notre
hôpital public est toujours à genoux
plus de 3 ans après le début de la crise
covid et malgré toutes vos belles
promesses les rapports alarmants se
multiplient sur la gestion de nos EHPAD
et maintenant de nos crèches nous ne
sommes toujours pas sortis du marché
européen de l'énergie qui fait s'envoler
les coûts pour les particuliers mais
aussi pour nos artisans dont plusieurs
milliers d'entreprises sont à l'agonie
nos collectivités locales rognent leurs
investissements abandonnent des projets
pour faire face à l'explosion de leurs
dépenses de fonctionnement et pendant ce
temps là dans le monde parallèle de la
macronie des ministres trouve le temps
d'écrire des romans érotiques d'exposer
leur vie privée ou de poser en
couverture de magazine People le
président refuse de recevoir les
syndicats pour apaiser la colère sociale
mais donne des interviews à Pif Gadget
et les députés de la majorité relative
eux nous proposent d'occuper plusieurs
heures de nos débats en commission et
maintenant en séance pourquoi pour
rendre obligatoire le pavoisement du
drapeau européen sur le fronton de nos
mairies mais vous n'avez pas honte vous
n'avez pas honte car à ce niveau là ce
n'est ni de la déconnexion ni du
décalage avec les préoccupations des
Français c'est carrément leur faire un
doigt d'honneur
c'est leur exprimer comme à votre
habitude et comme à l'habitude de le
faire Emmanuel Macron votre mépris à
l'heure où ils attendent au contraire de
l'empathie et des mesures urgentes et
concrètes notamment pour leur pouvoir
d'achat c'est aussi rabaisser le travail
et l'image de notre assemblée que vous
avez déjà tant abîmé depuis le début de
ce mandat avec vos 49-3 mais finalement
en lisant un peu la presse ces derniers
jours ce sont les députés de la majorité
qui parlent le mieux de cette
proposition de loi je les cite légiférer
sur quelque chose qui se passe déjà bien
l'objectif n'est pas de légiférer mais
de faire parler c'est un sujet
extrêmement secondaire disait le
président bourlan ce matin à la radio en
deux mots toujours par un député de
votre groupe une connerie parce
qu'effectivement dans une grande partie
des mairies de France le drapeau
européen côtoie déjà le drapeau
tricolore ceux qui ont envie de le
pavoiser le fond et ceux qui n'ont pas
ne le font pas que ce soit pour des
questions matérielles ou financières
pour les plus petites mairies et ça
n'est pas votre obligation ridicule qui
va d'ailleurs une fois de plus à
l'encontre du principe de l'île
bradministration de nos collectivités
territoriales et qui n'est assorti
d'aucune sanction qui changera les
choses sur le fond maintenant votre
proposition est un véritable outrage à
notre Constitution article 2 l'emblème
national et le drapeau tricolore bleu
blanc rouge si obligation il devait y
avoir cela ne pourrait valoir que pour
cette emblème nationale durement à qui
est défendu un outrage également pour le
vote des Français nous savons que vous
avez pour habitude de trahir leur
volonté mais référendum de 2005 55 % non
à une Constitution pour l'Europe non aux
fédéralisme européen et assez symboles
dont ce drapeau fait partie enfin
outrage à l'intelligence des Français et
moyens de propagande totalement ridicule
car ce n'est pas en imposant le symbole
de la Commission européenne que vous la
ferez aimer aux Français que vous leur
ferez oublier les injonctions de
Bruxelles sur nos finances publiques ou
sur notre système de retraite que vous
leur ferez oublier les ravages de la
mondialisation sauvage et des traités de
libre-échange sur nos industries et nos
agriculteurs les ravages de
l'immigration massive incontrôlées voire
encouragé
l'échec énergétique qui pousse nos
ménages dans la précarité nos
entreprises vers la faillite l'échec de
toute politique écologique qui ne se
veut que punitive et la liste est bien
longue pour résumer votre proposition
est une provocation
inutile une tentative de diversion
pitoyable elle participe à une inflation
législative et réglementaire dont seule
la France et quelques techno-croix de
Bruxellois ont le secret elle ne répond
à aucune attente à aucune demande des
Français et elle est contestable sur le
fond alors comme nous nous sommes pas
adeptes de l'effort inutile et encore
moins adeptes de vos stratégies de
communication nous voterons évidemment
contre ce texte allez plutôt rencontrer
les Français aller travailler sur les
vrais sujets et revenez nous voir avec
des propositions utiles et sérieuses
mettez-vous au boulot car l'heure n'est
vraiment vraiment pas au symbole
[Musique]
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Antoine léoman pour le groupe
la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente décidément
collègue macronise vous abaissez notre
assemblée comme vous êtes en Pétré sur
la réforme des retraites comme vous
n'arrivez pas à tourner la page vous
faites diversion avec des textes
inutiles sans consistance et sans
intérêt c'est pas une perdue car vous
pouvez compter sur nous pour ne jamais
tourner la page et pour vous rappeler
sur chaque texte que vous avez fait
passer en force cette réforme des
retraites quelle est illégitime et que
sans retrait l'opposition populaire ne
cessera pas alors de quoi parleons-nous
aujourd'hui pour occuper l'Assemblée
nationale de l'obligation de pavoiser
les drapeaux français européens sur
toutes les mairies de France est-ce que
vous vous rendez compte du ridicule de
ce que vous êtes en train de faire les
Françaises et les Français qui nous
regardent doivent avoir des yeux et
berlués et se demander ce que nous
sommes en train de faire pour les
Français l'urgence c'est la réforme des
retraites l'inflation les salaires qui
n'augmentent pas l'état de nos services
publics les classes et les maternités
qui ferment la crise de l'eau qui arrive
quoi encore la Cinquième République à
bout de souffle mais non nous allons
parler drapeau alors parlons-en le
ridicule de la situation est évident
puisque le rapporteur lui-même a déclaré
sur MC je cite ce texte ne répond pas
aux enjeux politiques et sociaux du
moment mais c'est bien de le reconnaître
monsieur le rapporteur alors il y a-t-il
une urgence absolue à faire une loi sur
le sujet non les drapeaux français
européens sont déjà pas voisés sur
l'essentiel des mairies et donc vous le
savez il y a ni urgence ni en jeu dans
les rares endroits où c'est pas le cas
il s'agit souvent de raison matérielle
et financière il est des petites
communes où il n'y a qu'un main il y en
a d'autres où il y en a que deux et où
depuis quelques temps on papote à côté
du drapeau français le drapeau ukrainien
alors allez-vous obligé ces mairies à
retirer le drapeau ukrainien pour y
mettre le drapeau européen
allez-vous obliger les mairies au petit
budget à acheter de nouveaux mains de
nouveaux drapeaux non bien sûr car nous
n'en verrez même pas cette loi au Sénat
parce que si vous l'envoyez au Sénat
vous vous ferez battre et vous le savez
comme vous avez été battu en commission
la dernière fois alors du coup vous avez
inventé un amendement pour retirer 90%
des communes de votre texte de loi et le
ridicule vous tue toujours pas bref vous
ne faites pas de la politique vous
faites de la communication et votre
méthode tient en deux mots diversion et
division la diversion j'en ai parlé j'en
viens à la division l'unique raison pour
laquelle vous présentez ce texte et pour
tracer une ligne entre ceux qui le vote
et ceux qui ne votent pas pour dire
qu'il existerait d'un côté ce qui
aimerait l'Europe et de l'autre côté
ceux qui seraient opposés mais vous
n'aurez pas ce que vous voulez parce que
l'évidence est sous nos yeux ce qui
n'aiment pas l'Europe c'est vous ceux
qui défendent l'idéal de fraternité
entre les peuples c'est nous et oui
oui c'est la nupette qui porte contre
vous l'idéal de liberté et de démocratie
dont vous vous gargarisez tout en
faisant passer votre réforme par 49-3 et
en réprimant le mouvement social qui s'y
oppose oui c'est la nupesse qui porte en
Europe le programme liberté égalité
fraternité en défendant la nécessité
d'une harmonisation sociale fiscale et
écologique par le haut vous vous ne
proposez qu’une Europe du marché du
libre-échange du productivisme et
considère du dumping social et fiscal et
de la compétition de chacun contre tous
chacun d'ailleurs a pu juger combien
vous n'aimiez pas l'Europe au regard de
vos arguments pour faire passer votre
retraite à 64 ans vous disiez regardez
dans les autres pays européens comme
c'est nul il faut que nous fassions
pareil alors que nous nous disions
regarder comme nous pouvons faire
progresser nos droits nous nous battons
pour les nôtres pour que vous puissiez
avoir les mêmes que nous voilà ce que
nous nous envoyons comme message aux
Européens l'Europe nous regarde elle
nous regarde nous et elle vous regarde
vous elle voit en nous un idéal et un
espoir dans la lutte elle voit en vous
l'autoritarisme et la répression ceux
qui font rayonner l'Europe en ce moment
la France en Europe en ce moment c'est
nous pas vous l'Europe et la
construction européenne collègues
macronisme ne tiennent pas dans
l'affichage d'un drapeau sur le fronton
des mairies alternes dans les mots et
dans les actes vous utilisez l'Europe
pour faire la compétition de chacun
contre tous nous voulons en faire un
lieu d'harmonie des droits démocratiques
sociaux et environnementaux alors oui
collègue macroniste votre plan de
diversion et de division à échouer et
vous vous payez même le ridicule d'avoir
divisé votre propre majorité en voulant
diviser les autres vous avez produit
l'inverse de votre objectif car pense en
faire diversion vous nous avez offert
une tribune pour appeler que la page de
la réforme des retraites n'est toujours
pas tourné et qu'elle ne le sera pas
vous avez produit l'inverse de votre
objectif car pensant créer de la
division dans la nups vous nous avez
offert la possibilité de rappeler que si
nous avons des appréciations différentes
sur le drapeau européen nous sommes
d'accord sur l'essentiel l'essentiel
c'est de prendre pour programme en
France et en Europe la devise Liberté
égalité fraternité et de prendre pour
méthodes d'action en Europe et en France
la devise de l'Union européenne unie
dans la diversité
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
Gosselin pour le groupe les républicains
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues quel débat malheureux en cette
Journée de l'Europe et demain à la
déclaration Schuman qui méritait mieux
alors même que le drapeau de la
République c'est Trois Glorieuses
couleurs qui ont été hissés hier 8 mai
dans toutes les communes de France
devrait nous réunir en ayant voulu
intégrer celui de l'Europe le drapeau
européen vous créez en réalité la
discorde vous vouliez unir vous divisez
et nous voilà lancés dans une bataille
des drapeaux qui paraît bien loin des
préoccupations de nos concitoyens et
vous tombez même dans la caricature tant
monsieur le rapporteur et je le regrette
chers collègues Lefebvre que madame la
ministre c'est très binaire on est pour
on est contre l'Europe en faisant des
raccourcis à la fois historiques
sémantiques idéologique qui n'ont rien à
voir avec le débat d'aujourd'hui mais
c'est très simple évidemment ça permet
de cliver non c'est en réalité plus
complexe et beaucoup plus subtile que
cela
vous vouliez mettre les symboles de la
République à l'honneur mais très bien
j'avoue humblement mais peut-être un peu
immodestement que j'avais eu la même
idée en 2021 dans le débat sur les
principes de la République et j'avais à
ce moment-là avec plusieurs collègues
fait un plaque un paquet global avec le
drapeau la devise de la République la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme et du
Citoyen voilà il y avait du sens et en
extirpait pas un sujet par rapport à
d'autres mais à l'époque la majorité
déjà de cette époque il y a à peine deux
anges je le rappelle nous disait avec
l'article 45 que c'était sans lien
direct ou même indirect avec le sujet
sans lien avec le sujet alors qu'il
s'agissait des principes de la
République bon la vérité d'hier n'est
plus celle d'aujourd'hui et inversement
et vous avez repris cette idée avec un
contexte économique social politique
très différent et ce qui nous amène à ce
débat assez tendu est-ce urgent
est-ce utile je crois que la réponse est
déjà connue mais puisque nous en sommes
là et bien des bâtons et le cas échéant
amplifions la logorrhée législative dont
le Conseil d'État dans son rapport de 92
c'était déjà largement fait l'écho
l'article unique B92
oui mais la logorrhée était déjà là elle
s'est amplifiée chers collègues grâce à
vous tous depuis quelques années
l'article unique de la proposition loi
dont nous débattons vise à rendre le
paroissement du drapeau européen
obligatoire aux côtés du drapeau
tricolore au fronton des mairies de
France or on rappellera que l'article 2
de notre Constitution celle de la
cinquième qu'il faut-il le rappeler a
été adopté par le peuple français par la
voie référendaire précise que l'emblème
national et le drapeau tricolore bleu
blanc rouge il n'est évidemment
aucunement fait référence au drapeau
européen aussi respectable soit-il comme
les d'ailleurs l'ardente obligation de
la construction européenne on peut avoir
des points de vue différents sur les
modalités sur le fonctionnement de
l'Europe plus ou moins fédérale etc mais
on doit saluer cette construction et je
le fais bien volontiers en cette journée
symbolique du 9 mai qui permet aussi de
saluer la réconciliation
franco-allemande or à l'exception des
dispositions constitutionnelles
précisées il n'y a aucun texte de valeur
qualitatives aux réglementaires qui
fixent les règles de pavoisement des
édifices publics seul l'usage et la
tradition qui sont pris en compte
permettent de le faire nos 36 000
communes et donc mairies sont autant de
petites républiques qui font de la
grande d'ailleurs Alexis Tocqueville
disait fort justement que c'est dans la
commune que réside la force des peuples
libres il y a donc de l'intérêt à voir
le drapeau tricolore partout dans cette
collectivité de base et je rappellerai
d'ailleurs que c'est la seule
collectivité de base qui soit présente
sur tout le territoire de la République
sans distinction hexagone et évidemment
outre-mer confondus donc il apparaît
souhaitable oui bien sûr que le drapeau
français flotte sur les bâtiments de nos
maisons communes comme on le disait dans
certaines textes autrefois la totalité
des élus ou la quasi-totalité le des
élus le font on notera qu'à l'occasion
de certaines commémorations officielles
de visite de chefs d'État d'autres
drapeaux sont déjà possibles et
autorisés évidemment on notera aussi
pays que rien ne s'oppose à ce que le
drapeau européen ou un autre régional
par exemple breton le Normand et celui
de ses léopard bien évidemment soit
présent de façon pérenne ou non ce qui
n'est pas interdit et licite c'est donc
déjà possible aux aujourd'hui alors
laissons notre drapeau européen mettons
notre drapeau français nous n'avons pas
de double légende le peuple est
souverain en France et l'article 3 de la
Constitution évidemment qui le rappelle
l'Europe n'est pas encore un état en
tout cas il n'y a pas de souveraineté de
l'Union européenne alors soyons
raisonnables la porte de sortie elle
n'est pas madame la Présidente dans le
rejet plus récent de ce texte mais elle
est dans l'adoption si l'on veut à la
rendre obligatoire du drapeau tricolore
au froton des mairies en laissant une
porte de sortie honorable pour tout le
monde qui est la faculté de mettre le
drapeau européen voilà comment nous
pouvons nous y retrouver sur tous les
bancs je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Erwan Balanant
pour le groupe démocrate modem et
indépendant
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
Louise Weiss Mélina Mercouri Nicole
Fontaine Simone Veil à la ligne Marga
campé Jean Monnet
vous entendez un peu ce que vous avez vu
le niveau
adénauer edmuncall François Mitterrand
mes chers collègues arrêtons-nous un
instant sur ces noms
sans doute certains d'entre vous
sont certains d'entre eux vous sont
familiers mais sans doute aussi d'autres
vous sont plus inconnus
loin d'une liste à la Prévert ces noms
peuvent expliquer à eux seul le monde
dans lequel nous Européens évoluons
aujourd'hui
combattant de la Résistance
survivant de nos locaux personnalité et
dirigeants politiques et même actrice de
cinéma
ces esprits visionnaires ont construit
les fondements de l'Europe dans lequel
nous vivons aujourd'hui
tous ont permis de tourner la page des
deux guerres mondiales tous ont promu la
paix et la solidarité tous ont défendus
l'État de droit et les valeurs
fondamentales à l'origine de l'Union
européenne ils sont les mers et les
pères fondateurs de l'Europe
leur courage leur abnégation leur foi en
cette Europe unie et solidaire nous
oblige
il nous oblige encore plus en cette 37e
journée de l'Europe où nous rendons
hommage à l'un des moments fondateurs de
l'Union européenne le 9 mai 1950 à Paris
le ministre des Affaires étrangères
Robert Schuman appelle à la mise en
commun des productions de charbon et de
l'acier en Allemagne conscient que cette
union ne se fera pas du jour au
lendemain il prononcera ses mots qui
résonnent encore plus en nous
aujourd'hui la paix mondiale ne saurait
être préservée sans des efforts
créateurs à la mesure des dangers qu'il
a menacent l'Europe ne se fera pas d'un
coup ni dans une construction d'ensemble
elle se fera par des réalisations
concrètes créant d'abord une solidarité
de fait je vois que ça fait beaucoup
rire les collègues du rassemblement
national
la force de l'Union européenne provient
de la solidarité entre ses membres
solidarités visiblement un mot qui vous
est pas très le moins cher un mot qui
vous est quasiment inconnu elle s'est
traduit à tous les niveaux encore
aujourd'hui plus que de simplement elle
se manifeste en acte entre les États
membres mais aussi avec nos États
européens les dernières années en sont
criante de vérité elle s'est traduit dès
le début de la pandémie de la covid 19
lorsque nous avons envoyé du matériel
médical en Italie puis au plus fort de
la crise lorsque l'Allemagne l'Allemagne
a accueilli dans ses unités de soins
intensifs des patients français
enfin en réponse à cette crise sans
précédent les dirigeants de l'Union
européenne se sont accordés sur un plan
de relance baptisé next generation
UE de 750 milliards d'euros pour la
période 2020 2027
autre situation autre exemple même
solidarité
au lendemain des premiers bombardements
en Ukraine l'Union européenne a condamné
sans hésitation la Russie tout en
prenant des mesures de rétorsion très
lourdes pour l'économie russe et en
décidant de manière historique de
financer l'envoi d'armes aux Ukrainiens
le pays c'est par ailleurs vu octroyer
le statut d'État candidat à l'adhésion à
l'Union européenne
s'il fallait encore s'en convaincre je
vous rappellerai rappellerai que cette
solidarité se traduit aussi en dehors en
dehors de tout événement extraordinaire
et elle est ancrée dans le
fonctionnement quotidien de notre union
l'un des beaux exemples et la politique
de cohésion des territoires cette
politique régionale qui vise à atténuer
les disparités les écarts de
développement entre les 242 régions de
l'Union européenne par un transfert de
ressources simple engagement préambule
du traité de Rome de 1957 la politique
de cohésion va progressivement s'imposer
aux États membres et au fur et à mesure
au fur et à mesure des l'élargissement
de l'Union européenne jusqu'à devenir
aujourd'hui un élément essentiel de son
bon fonctionnement preuve en est dès
1994 elle compte pour un tiers du budget
européen total fort de ces illustrations
et reprenant les mots du Livre Blanc
Europe du Mouvement Démocrate publié en
perspective de la présidence de
française de l'Union européenne je vous
dirai donc
l'Union européenne c'est d'abord un
projet commun visiblement que vous ne
partagez pas avec nous
fondée sur des valeurs humaines
humanisme de paix de solidarité qu'il
faut transmettre et incarner
incarner si le pavoisement du drapeau
européen aux côtés du drapeau tricolore
est un moyen de réaffirmer notre union à
l'Union européenne et à ses valeurs il
participera ainsi à la rapprocher de nos
concitoyens je vous remercie
monsieur Balanant
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues de baisser un peu
le son et de respecter les orateurs
quand ils sont à la tribune parce que
c'est particulièrement pénible
la parole est à Monsieur Hervé Solignac
pour le groupe socialiste et apparentés
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
faut-il être à court d'inspiration d'une
certaine manière pour nous proposer
légiférer sur un tel sujet
quand on est député de la majorité on
peut se payer le luxe de bien des PPL
avec normalement la quasi certitude de
la faire adopter et on a donc le devoir
de légiférer
utilement
les occasions de le faire ne manquent
pas tant notre pays se trouve confronté
à des défis majeurs vous auriez pu vous
saisir de la situation sociale de
l'inflation et de la baisse du pouvoir
d'achat de la crise démocratique
démocratique des déserts médicaux du
réchauffement climatique de la question
du logement de l'école ou que sais-je
encore mais non nous sommes là à
discuter des symboles à afficher sur les
bâtiments municipaux de la couleur du
drapeau et peut-être bientôt de la
taille des mains
chers collègues de la majorité je salue
ceux d'entre vous qui vont nous
expliquer ce soir et qu'ils l'ont déjà
fait avec force conviction combien cette
PPL est pertinente intelligente
visionnaire courageuse même peut-être ou
bien encore essentiel pour renforcer
l'attachement des Français aux valeurs
de la République et de l'Europe
en réalité la mairie est déjà en soi un
symbole de cette république de la
proximité elle est l'institution la plus
respectée des Français la plus appréciée
aussi elle est le lieu de la démocratie
locale des services du quotidien des
grandes étapes de l'existence le drapeau
s'y trouve déjà souvent accroché à sa
façade la devise républicaine presque
toujours gravée la liste des morts de
14-18 figurent en bonne place dans le
hall ou dans la salle du conseil le
portrait du Président de la République
Tron bien visible et les mères savent
très bien pavoiser quand ils le font le
8 mai le 14 juillet le 11 novembre ou
bien ce 9 mai Journée de l'Europe
la mairie est donc un concentré de
symboles mais il vous semble très utile
d'en rajouter une paire par une
obligation nouvelle alors
réjouissons-nous que vous n'ayez pas
imaginé une sanction pour les
réfractaires c'est peut-être parce que
la mairie est déjà une institution
solide reconnue et appréciée que vous
pensez pertinent d'en tirer profit la
vérité c'est que vous ne loupez pas une
occasion pour tenter d'enfoncer des
coins politiques
inutiles et si vous rajoutez
et si vous rajoutez de l'inflation à
l'inflation législative que dénonce
d'ailleurs le président lui-même peu
importe si vous créez une contrainte
nouvelle pour les maires qui en ont déjà
assez peu importe si vous abaissez le
rôle du Parlement peu importe alors il
faut des têtes bien naïfs pour
ignorer vos pièges grossiers et si nous
voterons ce texte c'est parce que les
socialistes ont la construction
européenne chevillée au corps et qu'il
est hors de question qu'on vous laisse
le loisir d'affirmer le contraire
depuis toujours les socialistes
défendent une Europe sociale une Europe
de la paix une Europe démocratique
humaniste nous en faisons la preuve au
travers de l'engagement de nos députés
européens
un attachement d'autant plus fort que la
guerre est à nos portes et je pense à
cet instant à ce jeune reporter français
de l'AFP qui a perdu la vie aujourd'hui
dans l'exercice de sa profession
plutôt que
d'imposer 35000 drapeau de l'Europe au
fronton au fronton de nos mairies soyez
simplement
exemplaires avec cette Europe ne
cherchez pas à contourner ses directives
ou à déroger à ses règles et alors vous
serez plus efficace qu'un drapeau pour
en assurer sa défense votre proposition
de loi est d'ailleurs tellement
rassembleuse qu'elle n'a pas réussi à
trouver de majorité en commission la
sagesse aurait dû vous commander de
retirer ce texte mais il est vrai que le
retrait n'est pas dans vos habitudes y
compris lorsqu'il vous est demandé
massivement
alors si vous voulez faire dans le
divertissement législatif faites-le mais
sachez deux choses premièrement ça se
voit les Français ne sont pas dupe
deuxièmement vous n'avez pas le monopole
de l'attachement à l'Europe en ce 9 mai
nous aurions pu fêter l'Europe il est
dommage que vous l'ayez instrumentalisé
pour diviser la représentation nationale
sur un sujet pourtant aussi précieux
voilà et la parole est à Madame Emmanuel
Ménard
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègue
voilà une proposition de loi qui n'a
aucun sens si ce n'est de servir des
calculs de basse politique on nous
propose un texte pour gêner pour mettre
dans l'embarras pour dénoncer les choix
de tel ou tel sûrement pas pour faire
avancer quoi que ce soit ou pour servir
une cause si ce n'est la vôtre même pas
une babiole un accessoire une bricole
même pas non un prétexte un simple
prétexte votre texte est d'un pénible
opportunisme qui ne relève d'aucune
nécessité ce pourrait être risible si
l'époque n'était à l'urgence
urgence qui manifestement ne vous
empêche pas de tremper dans des petits
jeux politiciens qui ne trouveront aucun
déco chez nos concitoyens mais
régaleront vos parties vos états majors
vos clientèles vos égaux vos petites
stratégies
quelle urgence y a-t-il à obliger les
mairies à mettre un drapeau européen sur
leur fronton pourquoi ce nouveau texte
ces nouveaux débats alors même que vous
reconnaissez-vous même monsieur le
rapporteur que ce texte ne répond pas
aux défis politique et sociaux du moment
rejeter en commission vous avez tout de
même maintenu son examen en vous
targuant de sa portée éminemment
symbolique mais n'avez vous pas compris
que les Français ne veulent plus de vos
textes éminemment symboliques ils
veulent juste des réformes de fonds et
d'envergure décidément vous êtes sourds
et aveugle je dis dernier on apprenait
que la France était le pays européen à
faire payer à ses automobilistes le prix
à la pompe hors taxes diverses et variés
le plus élevé alors que le cours du
pétrole est revenu à son niveau d'avant
guerre en Ukraine c'est la Commission
européenne qui le dit on constaté fin
avril un prix moyen hors taxe de 84
centimes dans la zone européenne
identique à celui d'avant février 2022
mais la France se démarque avec un prix
moyen hors taxes de 93 centimes soit une
hausse de 16% par rapport au prix
d'avant-gard chercher l'erreur cherchez
l'erreur quand les Français confronter à
la hausse des prix sont obligés de
jongler de faire des choix de ce privé
préoccupations quotidienne des Français
cette hausse des prix se traduit par un
net tour de vie sur les achats
alimentaires moins 9%, et des Russes
incessantes pour limiter les frais de
carburant à la pompe certains roulent
moins vite d'autres évitent l'autoroute
d'autres encore se mettent au
covoiturage mais personne personne ne
prend cela à la légère ni ne s'en amuse
mais pour vous l'urgence l'impérieuse
l'absolu urgence c'est de rendre
obligatoire la présence du drapeau
européen sur les frontons de nos mairies
faisant fi une nouvelle fois de votre
énième promesse de mieux et davantage
travailler avec les élus locaux ce texte
n'est qu'une mesure est
logique un bavardage inutile pire il est
contre-productif sous prétexte de
vouloir unifier les pratiques vous
imposer de nouvelles contraintes que
l'usage et la tradition républicaine
avait déjà largement intégré vous le
savez très bien la plupart des communes
comme chez moi à Béziers ou dans ma
circonscription pas voici déjà du
drapeau européen le fronton de leur
hôtel de ville nous y ajoutons même le
drapeau
occitan et celui de notre ville la plus
ancienne de France votre texte est
inutile et porte directement atteinte à
la libre administration des communes que
garantit l'article 72 de la Constitution
faites donc un peu confiance à nos élus
locaux pour une fois vous ne savez
qu'imposer de plus en votant ce texte et
nonobstant votre annonce de dernière
minute vous ferez supporter à certaines
communes notamment les plus petites de
nouvelles dépenses dont elles se
seraient bien passées
une nouvelle dépense une nouvelle loi
comme une comme s'il y en avait pas
assez ce n'était ce n'est plus une
inflation législative c'est une
indigestion législative que de temps
perdu que d'énergie gâchée alors
qu'Elizabeth borne affirmait dans sa
feuille de route vouloir mener de
grandes réformes nous les attendons
toujours mais elles sont sans cesse
repoussées retardées découper exit la
grande loi immigration définitivement
abandonné le texte tant attendu sur
grand âge et dépendance quel gâchis le
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires a donné
le mois dernier les chiffres exacts et
terribles des élus ayant mis fin à leur
mandat c'est plus de 40 par semaine soit
près de 4000 démissionneurs depuis les
élections municipales de 2020 tentative
d'intimidation manque de civisme
agression menace dénigrement casse-tête
bureaucratique c'est la liste des mots
qui gangrène notre démocratie locale
qu'il faudra bien plus qu'un drapeau
européen pour soigner mais si cela vous
permet de mettre des bâtons dans les
roues du rassemblement national et de la
France insoumise vous voilà satisfait en
réalité c'est tout juste médiocre merci
Madame Ménard
la discussion générale est close et je
donne la parole à Monsieur le rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
tout d'abord avoir une pensée pour
Armand soldat ce journaliste de l'AFP
qui a été tué à Bac mot et je pense que
nous sommes toutes et tous nombreux à
avoir une pensée pour lui ce soir
rapidement vous répondre à quelques
interrogations qui se sont fait jour
dans ce dans ce débat de deux choses
l'une soit ce texte était anecdotique et
dans ces cas-là il faut pas mettre un
acharnement tel à le combattre soit il
est symbolique et dans ces cas-là il est
important de le voter deuxièmement soit
toutes les mairies peuvent aujourd'hui
aux couleurs de l'Europe et de la France
et dans ces cas-là il s'agit conforter
un usage républicain soit ça n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui et dans ces cas-là il
faut pas combattre ce texte par ailleurs
par ailleurs mes chers collègues
évidemment vous nous dites c'est un
divers un divertissement législatif mais
mes chers collègues rien n'empêche la
mise en oeuvre d'une feuille de route
exigeante qui est celle qui a présenté
la première ministre pour répondre aux
problèmes des Français en revanche mes
chers collègues pardon mais dans notre
hémicycle le législateur a toujours jugé
bon de légiférer sur les symboles et en
2013 mes chers collègues quand
législateur a fait cela il a fait en
bonne intelligence avec le Sénat et dans
un esprit de concorde républicaine
encore une fois moi je ne comprends pas
ce qui a changé depuis 2013 peut-être
être l'apparition d'extrême plus
irruptive et plus radicale qu'auparavant
mais je ne vois pas pour quelle raison
nous serions incapables aujourd'hui de
faire pour les mes risques que nous
avons fait hier pour les écoles